my strategy to win big brother canada is
going to be a big social game big
flirtatious game showmance be everyone's
best friend but backstab when i need to
all right um what kind of personality
are you going to clash with in the house
the personality i think i'm going to
clash with the most in the house is
someone who's very laid back and not as
outgoing as me because i am the most
over the top all the time 24 7. so it's
a really chill person that i'm like come
on let's have some fun
do you think that that's not gonna rub
off onto you maybe to chill out a little
bit i think i'm definitely gonna have to
read the room when i walk in because i
am a big personality so i will be
perceived as a threat and i don't want
to be evicted night one so i'm gonna
have to tone it down a bit for sure
but it will always keep it stuff
um
[Music]
showmance
definitely a showmance because you're
locked away from society for so long and
i am a lover i wear my heart on my
sleeve and i love a good eye candy so
why not a showmance and again why uh
do you want to actually have somebody by
the end of this to like live life with
or do you want to
uh are you just using it
i think for sure at first i will be
using a showmance as a game move but who
knows once you're in there the heart
wants what it wants
cool
um and why is canada
this season canada is gonna root for me
because i'm gonna be the fun outgoing
bubbly but i'm gonna be so authentic and
i'm not gonna be afraid to show my true
colors and just be that person that i
know that everyone else loves on the
outside so why wouldn't canada love me
you